[Music]
on this tuesday night rescuing miners
trapped deep underground in ontario
the only way the 39 miners can get to
the surface is by climbing we want to
make sure that everybody comes out
safely we explain the grueling exit
route for miners trapped since sunday
ontario's cautious optimism about covid
plus its projections for what's coming
this winter as parents plea for better
protection for kids the prime minister
answers questions about the election for
the first time since the vote his new
government's top priority
and pivotal time at the plate the blue
jays have incredible amount of talent
the start of a crucial three-game series
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the rescue of
miners trapped deep in a mine in sudbury
ontario most of the 39 miners have made
the grueling journey climbing up to the
surface but three others are still not
free they have been stuck since sunday
afternoon the totten mine is owned by
vale a brazilian-based company
this is a promotional video that gives a
glimpse of what it's like deep inside
the copper and nickel mine it is a
modern mine opened in 2014 a highly
trained mine rescue team is now
assisting the only way out is a long
slow climb up about twelve hundred
meters using a system of ladders our
mike trolley is just outside the mine in
worthington ontario mike
donna we don't have to say what a
dangerous job mining can be any number
of things can happen when you're working
over a kilometer deep underground on
sunday it was a mechanical error
specifically the elevator or the cage
which is the lifeline to the mine
broke trapping 39 men underground and
the only way out was straight up
trapped they moved to refuge stations
for safety which were stocked with
minimal amounts of food and water rescue
crews were brought in from parent
company valet as well as ontario mine
rescue they determined the only way out
was to climb with ladders through a
secondary egress system which is
essentially a very narrow vertical tube
six meter long ladders were used to
connect each section of the evacuation
route the miners were attached to safety
harnesses but the majority of them still
had to climb out themselves one rung at
a time people are different physical
abilities and
and so you know that's a concern we want
to make sure that everybody comes out
safely and back to their families on on
surface some needed to be pulled up by
ropes it took up to 10 hours to reach a
surface to put it into context the
miners were at depths of 914 to 1219
meters or roughly two and a half cn
towers medical staff were on hand
throughout and no injuries have been
reported
and donna what's amazing to me speaking
to all the people leaving the mine is
just how calm and measured they are in
the face of such a terrifying ordeal
not a job for everyone donna certainly
isn't mike trolley in worthington
ontario near sudbury thanks
there is some cautious optimism about
the state of the pandemic in ontario the
latest projections reveal the province's
case count has plateaued but the
situation is fragile and numbers will
likely rise again as colder weather sets
in and people spend more time indoors
even if there is no change in public
health restrictions
right now the number of covet 19
patients being admitted to hospitals and
intensive care wards has gone down and
experts warn one piece of the puzzle is
missing kids under 12 who aren't
eligible for vaccines jamie morocco
reports
cova case after covid case has meant a
stressful start to the year for families
attending this toronto school it's just
mind blowing how little it feels has
been done to protect the kids the
ontario science table's latest modeling
shows while the province's overall case
counts have flatlined covet infections
in children 5 to 11 are still climbing
this is the very group
unfortunately who are going to be
susceptible to case spread at this point
because
kids are back in school and importantly
children under the age of 12 are not
eligible to be vaccinated yet pfizer has
not made a submission to health canada
to have its shot approved for ages 5 to
11 but officials hope a rollout could
happen by november we need to slow down
viral evolution and that means having
people vaccinated because they clear
infections when they clear the infection
then those vaccines those viruses do not
get to replicate and they have less
chance to mutate dr omar khan points to
the example of the delta variant a
mutation ravaging the unvaccinated
population worldwide here at home it's
clogging up icus in alberta where the
covet crisis is crashing the health care
system
at a park in ottawa this first time mom
is thankful to see vaccination rates in
ontario are increasing although slowly
if we can protect against any kind of
variant or any kind of spread then
that's something that we should do for
the unvaccinated like these little ones
the results can be long lasting the
science table estimates one in 10
ontarians infected with covid19 will
suffer symptoms for more than 12 weeks
doctors warn the province's positive
news is precarious we're certainly
taking the best case scenario from the
modeling that was projected about a
month ago and hopefully we can continue
along that best case scenario path with
kids back in doors as schools in full
swing and thanksgiving just around the
corner doctors say that cases will
likely go up before they come down it's
how ontario handles the vaccination
eligibility for children and how
residents adhere to restrictions that
will determine the future donna
jamie morocco in toronto thank you
children now account for nearly a third
of all the new covid 19 cases in
saskatchewan which has among the highest
number of active cases in the country
right now saskatchewan hospitals are
caring for more covid19 patients than at
any point in the pandemic and the rate
at which people are dying each day is
the highest in the country 10 new deaths
were reported today an average of 2.6
people per 100 000 are dying daily
that's nearly four times the national
average of 0.7
in prince edward island effective
immediately everyone who enters the
province will be tested at the airport
or at points of entry regardless of
their vaccination status school-aged
children who cannot be tested will be
given a self-test kit at the point of
entry to ensure they have a negative
test before they return to school the
province's chief public health officer
also says now is not the time for
discretionary travel
and two days after being freed from a
chinese prison michael kovrig is doing
his part to advocate for covid19
vaccines
a toronto pharmacist shared this moment
with kavrig's permission saying it was a
pleasure to give him a dose of covid19
vaccine and he tweeted what is said to
be a quote from kovrig i want everyone
to know this vaccines are the best way
to combat this disease
prime minister justin trudeau held his
own photo up at a vaccine clinic today
and said if you are planning to book a
flight in the next few weeks you'd
better get vaccinated for the first time
he answered questions about winning a
second minority he said his cabinet will
be sworn in next month and that
christian freeland will continue her
dual role as deputy prime minister and
finance minister our chief political
correspondent david aiken was at the
press conference david did the prime
minister seem at all humbled by the fact
he didn't win the majority he'd hoped
for
i don't think so donna and he we was
challenged a few times about the fact
that for the second election in a row
another party actually got more votes
than his did even though of course the
liberals got the most seats and he was
reminded that three members of his
cabinet went down to defeat last week
but nonetheless justin trudeau said that
election gives him a mandate for the
broad strokes of his platform my
intention is to continue to deliver to
canadians the ambitious mandate that
they voted us in on that mandate
includes being more ambitious when it
comes to climate change and moving ahead
with child care deals with provinces
like ontario and alberta that have not
yet inked a deal with ottawa but first
he has to form a new cabinet that will
likely be done by mid-october and as he
has in every cabinet since he formed
government in 2015 there will be an
equal number of men and women and the
top priority for that new cabinet will
be getting canada and canadians safely
through the pandemic chiefly by
improving vaccination rates right across
the country and so watch for trudeau to
make good on campaign promises that
include mandatory vaccination for all
federal civil servants and new rules
that will require anyone getting on a
plane or a train to be fully vaccinated
and when parliament resumes and that's
likely to happen in mid-november watch
for new legislation to make it a
criminal offense to harass or intimidate
frontline healthcare workers and that
too was a campaign promise donna okay
david and i want to ask you about huawei
5g wireless technology the u.s britain
australia and new zealand have all
banned or restricted it and the canadian
government has said for years that a
decision on it is imminent was there any
news today
well the official line is still canada
is studying the issue but unofficially
it sounds very much that the government
is simply trying to avoid having to
formally ban huawei
we've actually seen that many canadian
telecommunications companies if not all
of them have
started to remove huawei from their
networks and are moving forward in ways
that doesn't involve them as a company
many though are now saying the huawei
decision should be part of a broader
review of canada-china business
relations so i think now is really a
time to have our our eyes very open
in terms of
you know china and who we might doing
business with but also what the options
are
and that might mean a higher priority on
protecting national security protecting
intellectual property rights of canadian
companies even if that comes at the
expense of some sales to china donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
america's top military leaders get
grills coming up what they didn't expect
about the chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan plus
blah blah blah blah blah blah
why greta tunberg is mocking world
leaders
it was america's longest war it was a
war america lost and it ended in a
chaotic violent withdrawal with
desperate afghans clinging to evacuation
flights and a suicide bomb attack that
killed dozens of people including 13 u.s
soldiers one month later the first
hearings about what went wrong are
underway in washington the u.s secretary
of defense admitted today there are
tough questions to be asked and
uncomfortable truths to face jackson
proskow reports
the hasty american exit from afghanistan
drew fire on capitol hill we left behind
thousands of afghans who served us along
south side of us who were vetted and
approved to come here lawmakers pressed
the defense secretary and top generals
on the chaotic withdrawal
a retreat that left the taliban in
control 13 american soldiers and dozens
of afghan civilians dead and an unknown
number left behind an unforced
disgraceful humiliation that didn't have
to happen
under oath the generals admitted they
didn't see it coming what did we miss
we absolutely missed
the rapid 11 day collapse
of the afghan military and the collapse
of their government they also testified
they recommended president biden violate
a withdrawal deal between former
president trump and the taliban and
leave a force of 2500 u.s troops in the
country if we went below that number in
fact we would probably witness a
collapse of the afghan government and
the afghan military that contradicts
what biden has previously claimed they
wanted you to keep about 2500 troops no
they didn't it was split
that wasn't true the generals believe
staying beyond august 31st all but
certainly would have led to a new war
with the taliban
leaving has exacted a toll on american
credibility damage is one word that
could be used yes
especially because there's no longer any
american presence in the country no
diplomats and no one to monitor threats
from al qaeda the very thing that
started america's longest war
the fact that the war in afghanistan
spanned two decades and four different
presidents has led to calls for a
broader investigation not just into what
went wrong with the withdrawal but how a
mission focused on nation building
delivered almost no measurable results
donna jackson proskow in washington
thanks the head of the world health
organization calls it a dark day for the
who an investigation into allegations of
sexual abuse and exploitation during an
ebola outbreak in the democratic
republic of the congo found widespread
abuses more than 80 aid workers
including 21 employed by the w.h.o are
accused of sexual abuse and exploitation
during the 2018 ebola crisis some
victims were as young as 13 nine
allegations involved rape the
investigation found victims were
promised jobs in exchange for sex or in
order to stay employed
today the director of the w.h.o called
the report harrowing and apologize to
the victims
i'm sorry
i'm sorry for what was done to you by
people who were employed by w.h.o
to serve
and protect you
i'm sorry for the ongoing suffering that
these events
must cause
of the 21 employees identified by
investigators four were still working
for the un health agency this month
their contracts have now been terminated
but the police and the courts are not
involved in investigating or charging
anyone
pandemic pivot ahead a look at what's
driving women to shift gears to better
careers
[Music]
you're watching global national
there is no planet b
there is no planet blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
that is swedish climate activist greta
tunberg taking a shot at world leaders
for failing to deliver on their promises
to address the climate emergency she was
speaking at the youth climate summit in
milan according to the u.n carbon
emissions are set to rise by 16 percent
by 2030 rather than falling by half
which is the cut that's needed to keep
global warming below the internationally
agreed limit of 1.5 degrees celsius
[Music]
we know not everyone has been affected
by the pandemic the same way there are
huge variations based on your job your
health and your socioeconomic background
and lots of women have had to rethink
their careers or reinvent them
altogether tonight in the first of a
series on pandemic pivots and gaviola
explains how some women are breaking
barriers and making profits
the pandemic did a number on dana cobb's
finances when her office shut down
during covid the mother of two wasn't
making enough to pay her bills so she
founded screw it contracting early this
year one day my grandmother approached
me and told me she had thought of
something
when she said it was screw it i burst
out laughing and immediately fell in
love with it
woodworking has been her hobby for two
decades and now she does it for a living
honestly right from the get-go it's
really taken off i've been busy every
single day without stop
definitely an increase in in my income a
bit
some provinces like british columbia
have seen more women enter trades during
the pandemic mirroring a national trend
i think what's happened in many cases is
you know as in other sectors through the
pandemic people stopped and paused and
rethought you know you know their life a
little bit and priorities
but canada faced a skilled trade
shortage pre-pandemic and the covid
renovation boom has only increased
demand for these services an estimated
700 000 skilled trades people are
expected to leave the workforce and
retire within the next seven years
according to the latest research from
rbc and that means even more of these
workers are going to be needed in these
fields
michelle crisp left her job as a
personal trainer three years ago to
found her own contracting company she
says being handy runs in the family my
dad is like a
true renaissance man he's kind of a jack
of all trades he could do everything
from fix a car it's a plumbing
electrical framing drywall during covid
she's quadrupled her staff hiring all
women doing her part in an industry that
hasn't always been welcoming to women
the patriarchy is pretty deep in this
world
misogyny and everything else a lot of
the people that reach out to me are are
females i find that they feel a lot more
comfortable with having a female
contractor in their home
she hopes her pandemic pivot encourages
other women to get outside their comfort
zone and try something that really pays
off
ann gaviola global news toronto
toronto makes noise for a wild card
showdown next the blue jays push to the
playoff
the toronto blue jays have returned home
to twice the stadium noise ontario's
government has allowed rogers center to
double the seating capacity it's now
capped at 75 percent which is about 30
000 people everyone must be fully
vaccinated and it's just in time for a
make or break series opener the blue
jays are in a three-way race to win one
coveted spot and as erik sorensen
reports young talent may be the team's
ticket to the top
this team is a joy to watch not just a
power hitting playoff contender they're
so cheerful doing it the home run jacket
just one feature of a club that is young
and talented led by 22 year old
superstar vladimir guerrero jr yeah they
have fun with it there's a lot of energy
with this team and that comes naturally
from being young and guerrero's
personality is a great part of that he
is not only something that
hardcore fans really love to watch but
more casual fans can turn on a game and
really fall in love with after a
lackluster august the jays are now in
the thick of it in late september we
just have to win and again
i just
i'm so proud of this team you know to be
where we are right now the goal of every
major league team is to make the post
season for the blue jays this is their
45th season and only eight times have
they made the playoffs this year they're
in the race down to the wire in the
american league the three division
leaders all qualify for the postseason
and then the next two best teams make
the wild card the yankees the red sox
and the blue jays have the next three
best records and they are neck and neck
and neck for the wild card game so three
games this week against the yankees
could make or break their season finally
playing in toronto and with extra fans
allowed this week up to 30 000 of them
it's the first playoff atmosphere around
the home park in a long time honestly
super exciting especially with the push
to the playoffs right now i can't wait
to see the blue jays clinch the final
position guerrero junior leads a
charismatic core of players including
bobachet lourdes goriel and teosco
hernandez and pictures robbie ray jordan
romano and yet another young phenom alec
manoa blue jays have an incredible
amount of talent it's just about putting
it together but a lot of these young
stars that are really going to grow the
game hopefully playoffs or busts this
year it is a team that will be fun to
watch in more ways than one for years to
come eric sorensen global news toronto
so exciting and that is global national
for this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is desert lake
just north of the community of
hartington ontario thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you